I want to pull up this tweet from Alvin
Elon Musk responded to this tweet with
an exclamation point he said dear God
what the f I give you now this image
threads an Instagram app I'll give you
the short version they're basically
spying on you in every way imaginable
data safety let's see data shared
personal info device or other IDs data
collected
location personal info Financial info
health and fitness messages photos and
videos audio files and docs calendars
contacts app activity web browsing app
info and performance device or other IDs
now that's amazing did you say it's
encrypted can you say no to those
there's these carrot drop downs on the
right can you click those I mean this is
an obviously interactable this is
basically saying what they're doing so
look at this like you have to opt in
they have your location they have your
name email user ID address phone number
political or religious beliefs sexual
orientation a lot of times you'll be
able to opt out yeah but they'll opt you
in if you don't know they take your
financial info your credit score you are
giving them is this for if this is
legitimate I just want to make sure like
someone someone posted this and assuming
this is real like you're giving your
credit score your health info and
fitness info so how much you weigh your
your blood levels advertisers must be so
aroused right now this is everything
you're giving your email Voice or sound
recordings files and documents quite
literally it can go into your calendar
events what is that all of your content
look at your all your videos on your
phone the contacts is crazy because if
some random person that never signed up
for social media is in my phone then now
Instagram has them and they'll start
marketing to them
well it's not just even more insidiously
we know the federal government has been
working with social media companies if
they can see who's following who like
who's not just following on social media
but actually who has who in their
phone's contacts that's really really
scary yeah I always saw that someone at
it's a former CIA uh employee someone
that worked for CIA is now moved over to
I believe it was Facebook meta I'm
looking for the Tweet now but I actually
had an experience a couple weeks ago
Alex Jones was on the pbd podcast
Patrick Beth David and he asked some
question on there like if we install in
Russia if there's like a new leader is
installed and they're sympathetic to the
West what will happen and nobody really
had an answer and I was going to text
him Alex and be like well I think that
would move us towards totalitarian you
know technocracy a little bit faster
more peaceful but also that and I just
didn't message him he's like I don't
want the FBI reading my what a
I was so angry at myself that I
didn't be brave like I just so the the
guy that is for the ca Aaron Berman
former 17-year CAA officer is now head
of Elections policy for Facebook and
Instagram Berman joined Facebook in 2019
and was responsible for writing
misinformation policy and enforcing it
for the 2020 election covid Brazilian
elections Etc he's joined by 15 other
CIA FBI and DHS working in trust and
safety so so real quick I did confirm
these images it's in the Play Store it
is real can you drop them down on the
right one thing I want to do real quick
though is I want I I went to the Twitter
app on the Play Store I do not see the
same thing it doesn't have anywhere
yeah it doesn't have this stuff do you
who's that guy that tweeted that because
I want to take a look and retweet that
this is so hard to navigate that's not
so when I go to Twitter I don't see it
let me try let me see what truth social
does data safety starts with you blah
blah blah see the details uh
so data collected from truth social your
personal info email address is user ID
phone number messages other in-app
messages photos and videos contacts app
activity info performance and device IDs
that's actually all normal right the
reason why it says photos and videos and
this is true for meta is because you
post them so it needs access to those
you know it doesn't have anything else I
mean contacts are there because it'll
ask you in-app messages I don't care
about your email address well of course
you log in sign in with that so it
really it is true that uh uh threads by
Instagram is basically audio files like
it's taking everything yeah it's it's
probably it's the same thing that Tick
Tock does I wonder if Instagram does the
same thing people talked about the the
amounts of data that Tick Tock collects
sounds like thread does threads does the
same Instagram has basically the same
thing it does Instagram basically takes
everything as well yeah this is Facebook
this is what they do and like knowing
that man how can how can people it's
just such a convenient tool but it's so
Insidious that they're tracking
not your every move but all right
Twitter your psychology Twitter takes
um not nearly as much it doesn't access
your files and documents but it does
have quite a bit of information your web
browsing history Twitter takes uh
app functionality analytics advertising
and marketing your web browsing history
Twitter takes that too so it looks like
Twitter is very bad threads is
substantially worse but don't be
surprised when everyone's spying on you
and I'll just make sure it's clear that
I don't want to single out threads on
this one
they are spying on you to a greater
degree than the other ones but uh
they're all spying on you quite a bit
well I mean anyone if anyone who has an
Alexa or a Google home assistant or
whatever they're called that is
essentially a wiretap that you've
allowed into your home all these phones
are this phone is tracking me right now
because if you say uh let's what is the
thing voice activation Okay Google
it Buzz why I push the button oh okay
how can I help
if your phone TV or any other device has
voice activation that means it is
listening to every single word you say
very likely recording it and
transmitting it well it has to record it
the way voice activation works is that
it records what you say sends it to a
company for analysis who then scan it
for Tech to convert it to text and sends
it back to the TV so if your TV
is voice activated many people have this
now if you can just walk up and say
something like Okay Google or whatever
it every word out of your mouth gets
sent to this company for analysis and
it's just waiting to hear the activation
command
they save all that data of course they
keep it all what they say is don't worry
it's anonymized we don't actually know
who you are and I'm like yeah yeah you
know who you are because I'm talking
about who I am you're you can't really
have all of my personal conversations
and say it's anonymous because no it's
not that's not how conversations work
but uh our our TV actually has something
where we can turn off the the voice
activation function like uh through the
hardware like a lot of laptops have that
with uh webcams now but if you do that
there's a stupid little light that will
remain on and it's annoying because they
want you to have the thing open right
because they want to be listening to you
they also uh this Alvin guy also posted
this app privacy from Instagram and it
says the following data may be collected
and linked to your identity health and
fitness Financial info contact info user
content browsing history usage data
Diagnostics purchases locations contacts
search history identifiers sensitive
info and other data what does that mean
my favorite is credit score it said
credit score a credit score dude
Zuckerberg just wants to know everything
about you yeah I think it's because
that's crazy I mean think about what
that means for advertisers if they're
plugged into your credit score they can
actually bid to advertise on people who
have good credit scores like if you're a
credit card or something like that
that's scary that's missing you know
what I wonder if like maybe the AI took
over a long time ago and it's just
learning everything possible about us it
feels you don't realize we're under its
spell it feels inevitable I don't know
if I'm like if I'm um broken and I'm
just like giving up or if it's actually
inevitable the AI takeover not like
electricity didn't take us over we
weren't taken over by it we just all use
it mostly so AI it might be similar it
might not take us so it might just don't
use it but uh what a powerful tool
especially when it can talk to you and
tell you things
what the AI the artificial intelligence
it's freaking weird man no ai ai really
scares me and it's a it's also kind of
ironic and people have been posting
about this like we assumed Ai and like
technology would come so we would be
relieved of menial jobs especially like
that's the dream if you're on the left
but instead it's like all the the
creatives that are being put out of work
almost first I mean obviously technology
has been for a long time phasing out
lower skilled jobs but it's like now
even the good jobs that people were
aspiring to those are the ones that are
also being wiped out by AI like you know
the the graphic designers the writers
yeah it's like it's less about can you
physically draw the picture now and and
more about can you conceive of the the
description verbally and then give the
computer an accurate like inter uh
intricate descriptive so it's come up
with it it's another type of art form
it'll produce another generation
actually so I I did a poll on that on my
Twitter and it was quite the Lively
debate whether AI art actually counts as
art is it art what is art I mean that's
philosophical about it I I think it is
art a lot of people will say it is not
art if it's created by AI incorrect it
is I I agree because I think there are
so many different tools that we have
evolved throughout time using to create
art why are we placing the limit on AI
yeah because if you use a laser to carve
something in the wood yeah and I mean
people will say well oh it's it's just a
an amalgamation of previous art isn't
that any art anyway we are the pro like
creation is usually the product of you
know I guess absorbing other works and
then your own interpretation when
someone paints a picture and uses the
tool you know paints or a paintbrush or
whatever it is they're using now people
can do all sorts of different crazy art
they'll take like coins and then line
them up so it makes a big picture
the AI is just basically a paintbrush
what you input into it may not actually
be good art you might say hey make this
picture it makes one you say hey
everybody look what my AI thing did and
you're like that's stupid and then
someone might put it in refine it put
the photo back in say change this change
that and then refund to the point where
it actually makes a really cool picture
but admittedly it's just getting easier
and easier to make stuff the scary thing
about it is if all art is just
derivative of other art then eventually
all art will be derivative of ai ai will
just be regurgitating the same things
without new human thought and input but
it's it's crazy because I mean we like I
I've been working on stuff with like
different logos and we are working with
a graphic designer like an actual person
to come up with stuff and then one day I
was like you know I'm just going to try
one of these AI logo generators I just
want to see because we're kind of like
we're at an impasse nothing's really
like sparking man the AI ones were good
oh wow they were really good they were
better there's like man this is actually
solid and it's faster and it's cheaper
but you know I want to support for the
actual person but it's just hard when
the AI product is in a lot of ways
genuinely better I want to point out a
couple articles real quick because uh
we're talking about threads and uh even
though a bunch of people on the left are
are trying to abandon Twitter for this
look at this one from Vice I've seen
posts you people wouldn't believe the
birth of an awful Mutant baby a man
explaining the symptoms of acute
radiation poisoning are similar to panic
all those moments will be lost in time
like post from 2012. this is this is
they're talking about threads it says
threads is an assault on the senses once
you've experienced it it's impossible to
scrub from memory threads is a
kaleidoscope of disturbing images and
unpleasant information a cautionary tale
to be avoided and a revelation of truth
that feels Stark and unavoidable
I like this one too look at this slate
writes meta's new threads app is
terrible it just might bury Twitter the
first sentence is good the second
sentence is bad but uh yeah it is it is
absolutely awful if you can't even get
the left to cheer for this app dude I
don't know what you're gonna I think
they really messed up by opening up the
fire hose of data to new users and
making them see tons of people that they
weren't interested in rather than give
them like five categories have them Auto
subscribe to like five accounts or ten
accounts and let them find their way
because having to block people the
minute you walk into a social network is
the most anti-social tactic or technique
you do not want your users blocking each
other that's like a failure of the
system well so here's the thing with uh
with threads right so like you know
again I'll pull it up
and if I go to my my home feed let's
just see uh who we end up with like
Paris Hilton
I I don't care to follow Paris Sultan
but I don't want to block paracels
exactly right because at some point in
the future Paris might do something that
gets re-threaded or whatever and and you
know maybe run for president it's like I
want to see that post then I got to be
like oh they did I better go unblock
them to see it that's ridiculous but
that's what happens when it's a bunch of
random people I mean what is why is it
recommending Taylor Lorenz to me thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time